so last body type is called the liver
body type the liver is located right
here on the size of a football it's
three and a half pounds put your hand on
your liver it's on the right side the
military right over here okay good
your liver is kind of an extra organ you
don't really need it
I'm just being sarcastic the liver if it
becomes dysfunctional you're going to
start getting more of a protruded
potbelly okay you ever see the guy in
the beach of the speedo sorry to give
you that image but that's kind of like a
basketball belly it's hard it's higher
if you take your hand on one side and
tap it it'll create a little ripple why
because most of its fluid it's called
ascites the fluid means fluid it's
leaked the livers leaking fluid into
that sac right there
so how many sit-ups won't work sit-ups
won't work their legs are skinny it's
just right there it's not just beer it's
actually fluid coming from destruction
of the liver the two foods that destroy
the liver our heavy cooked proteins
animal proteins heavy cooked texas-style
steaks this thick big ones every night
before you go to bed deep fried food
deep fried catfish will do it too just
all that fat in meat will just destroy
the liver so the worse the liver the
more you can't tolerate the heavy
proteins the older you get the less you
can tolerate red meat so what happens is
that you want to adjust the food based
on your weakness but the good thing
about the liver it's the only organ that
completely regenerate a hundred percent
but the bad news is it takes three years
of eating a certain way okay the liver
is the hub of so many things the liver
will cause of liver problem will cause
pain on the right side right shoulder
why is it on the right shoulder the
livers on the right it's going to be
swell up it's going to go right here you
have a liver problem don't sleep on your
left side because it's too heavy it's
going to compress the heart you can feel
uncomfortable you'll sleep on the right
side the liver will create a little red
spots on your skin little red dot skin
psoriasis eczema little liver spots ET
skin hot feet white tongue that's a
yeast chronic halitosis that's bad
breath sometimes they usually talk to
you very close to front of your face
they don't know that they have bad
breath it's like really they have a lot
of digestive bloating okay now the liver
makes bile now there's a confusion about
bile some people think it's bowel and it
no that's bow bile bi L II bio helps
it's like the detergent that breaks down
the grease it helps you digest the fats
and it helps you absorb the fat vitamins
that side the vitamins vitamin A if
you're deficient about M&A you're going
to have a hard time seeing at night
you're going to have sinus problems
you're going to dry skin you can have a
little yellow thing in your inside of
your eye right here a little tag there
there's a lot of issues with vitamin A
vitamin D you're going to problems with
calcium you're going to problems with
seasonal depression vitamin E you're
going to have problems with libido
vitamin C a e D and K you're going to
bruising so you have a lot of other
issues just for me done a bio how do you
know if you don't have bile you're going
to bloat when you eat you're going to
get bloating burping belching headache
on the right side ninety-eight percent
of headaches and migraines are coming
from that right there try an experiment
next time you get a headache press right
here on your gallbladder just press
right there and just hold that for two
minutes you'll hide like we'll go right
away the problem is not in your head
it's in your down here because when you
step on a dog's tail he barks to his
mouth right okay I'm just checking
so we get bloating burping belching many
people don't have the bile and their
bloat when they like at night they feel
like you're pregnant
yet during the day they're a flat
stomach is that real to anyone okay so
the liver they crave deep fried catfish
they like deep fried anything because
they're not absorbing it so you're going
to want the stuff that you can absorb
the other symptom is that when you eat
you're going to need a little sweet
after you eat you need that little sweet
because you're not digesting fats to
satisfy your blood Sugar's okay you're
going to be grouchy in the morning
because you have a low blood sugar in
the morning how many work with people
that are grout you in the morning okay
so what you do on Monday when you go
back to work just go up to go up to the
guy hey John listen you know I've been
holding a grudge on you because you've
been very kind of grouchy but now I know
it's just your litter I forgive you
or the next time you go the
all-you-can-eat buffet just go online
excuse me sir
I've never had your liver checked do you
have any right shoulder pain do you ever
H in the bottom of your feet let me see
your tongue for a second here's dr.
Berg's card you might want to give him a
call
do you get bloating by the way I
actually don't mention my name if you
say that they might get offended see the
problem with teaching you the seminar is
you're going to want to evaluate
everyone you know everywhere you go
you're going to spot Oh liver Authority
- sorry
so that is liver liver is they do very
well on cruciferous vegetables okay